check out this week's must-see movies  you can save your friends or you can  save us all a young hero leads his  friends on their final and most  dangerous mission yet in Maze Runner the  death cure in desolation three people  travel into the remote wilderness on a  solemn mission but are disturbed by a  mysterious hiker what do you want 19 men  attacked our country the 12 of you will  be the first ones to fight back in 12  strong a Special Forces team takes on  the Taliban after 9/11 the only way home  is winning see what's hot in theaters  with this week's fantasy patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]